what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
Peter shift is the chief economist and
global strategist at Euro Pacific
Capital in this conversation we
discussed the history of money the macro
economy the current signs of an
impending crisis why he is so bullish on
gold what his concerns around Bitcoin
are and then Peter confirms that bitcoin
is scarce and that it can't be censored
or seized I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
skirt school want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right crypto
comm they're a crypto platform with one
goal mother in mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto calm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto calm
go help your boy out tell them pump sent
you download the app or visit crypto
comm pumps got you always everyone to
get into mining and didn't know how
don't worry your boy comps gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine it's like an
xbox or a PlayStation that helps you
turn your electricity into Bitcoin
that's right you purchase it it shows up
at your doorstep you pull it out of the
box you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mind comm tell
them tom sent you and thank me later
as many of you know crypto investors
store their digital assets on exchanges
or in cold storage for long-term
safekeeping however this strategy
doesn't help them grow their investment
holdings or build overall wealth with
the new block buy in
just account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or ether at block
fie and receive 6% annual interest paid
monthly in cryptocurrency 6% is an
absurdly high rate it's the best rate in
the industry I highly suggest you go
check out block Viacom / pump again
that's block 5 com / pop to sign up and
start earning crypto today if you follow
Bitcoin and crypto
you've probably heard of eToro they're
the world's number one social trading
platform and I love it they've got more
than 10 million other traders that love
it - and guess what they just launched
the United States eToro offers access to
the world's most popular crypto
currencies including Bitcoin etherium
and others with the smartest trading
tools and the ability to connect with
the best traders around the world
there's no better place to build your
perfect portfolio if you're new to
Bitcoin and crypto you can test the
waters with a one hundred thousand
dollar virtual trading feature but if
you're more experienced you can create
custom technical charts and use eToro
social fees to inform your trading
decisions they've got transparent fees
and so you never miss out they also have
an easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each row calm again that's eToro comm
get VIP access to Bitcoin and crypto
markets today Anthony Pappalardo is a
partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang bang I finally have
the man the myth the legend Peter Schiff
he is he is here and ready to explain
everything about gold Bitcoin and why he
has heavy bags but thanks so much in all
seriousness thanks for coming on and
doing this Peter sure palm place for
inviting me on yeah so look before we
get into I think what everyone actually
wants to hear let's go through your
background because as I've talked to
folks I don't think most people outside
of the hard
golde community really know what you've
done and kind of how you've built a
number of these businesses who just kind
of where'd your career start let's kind
of go through step by step how you got
to today well I just got my start in the
investment industry after I got out of
college I kind of got into futures and
options and was working in those markets
kind of just as a retail broker and
early on I kind of realized that there
was a lot of gambling involved there and
you know the brokers were making money
which was great for me but it was hard
to make money for the clients
consistently because you know by the
time you finished charging of a
commission that they kept on trading you
could potentially beat the markets but
it was hard to overcome the Vig of the
Commission so I didn't stay in
commodities down long and then I got
into the stock market I started working
at Lehman Brothers for a while and I was
kind of disillusioned there I think
didn't really like the the you know
strategies or the management again I
thought it was more focused on the firm
and not as much on the retail client and
I really wanted to build my business
based on you know doing what I thought
was right for the client in the long run
and I thought you know that would
ultimately benefit me more than some of
the shortcuts that I saw brokers taking
out back at Lehman and so I kind of
started my own firm and I bought a small
broker dealer that really didn't have
any clients that some guy had set up in
Florida and I bought it and renamed it
Euro Pacific Capital and that was back
in about 1996 1997 and so at that time
the US stock market was going through
the dot-com bubble and so what I really
started to do at that time with my
clients was start warning about that
bubble and encouraging people to take
profits or get out of the Nasdaq and get
out of the dot-coms and of course I was
a few years too early on that because as
I was telling people to sell these
stocks they kept going up but I was
confident
that this was a bubble and that it would
end badly and so I was buying people you
know the stocks that I thought who do
well in the aftermath of that bubble
poppy you know everybody wanted new
economy and so I was buy an old economy
you know I was buying gold stocks but I
was buying oil stocks I mean the oil was
under $20 a barrel no one wanted it I
was buying in Russia I was buying in
Kazakhstan you know then I was buying
the utilities in New Zealand Australia I
was buying stuff in Hong Kong and some
emerging markets and nobody wanted that
stuff and so it was going down but when
the.com bubble popped in 2000 and you
know I had been forecasting a 90% drop
in the Nasdaq and you know it dropped
80% so it didn't quite hit 90 but pretty
pretty close but when that happened
that's when all my stuff turned you know
the dollar had been and you know very
high during that calm era when we had
budget surpluses and people were saying
oh we're gonna pay off the national debt
we have surpluses as far as the eye can
see and I knew that was a bunch of
nonsense so when the dollar peak did it
went on about a eight year decline and
it hit an all-time record low by 2008
you know we made a tremendous amount of
money in the foreign stocks the emerging
markets and gold stocks that kind of
that party ended in 2008 ironically with
the financial crisis which was something
that I then began to forecast for years
because once the dot-com bubble popped
and the fence last rates to 1% III began
warning about a much bigger bubble that
the Fed was inflating in the housing
market and how this was going to be all
even more damaging than the the.com
bubble that they had plated and I even
wrote a book about it called crash proof
how to profit from the coming economic
collapse I wrote most of that book in
2005 and was finished by early o 6 and
it finally was published in early oh 7
when it came out and you know it was
pretty prescient as far as the timing
and then you know the dot-com bubble
popped
we had the collapse of the mortgage
market along the way I helped set up a
hedge fund that shorted the subprime
market in 2006 and that that paid off
peak in a big way in 2007 for us but you
know I all of a sudden that I got some
notoriety because I have been going on
CNBC and Bloomberg at Fox Business the
CNBC the CNN s CNN pretty much every
week for about two or three years from
2005 through 2008 I was like a regular
guest and I was the one guy that was
saying this is a bubble is the phony
economy housing prices are gonna crash
the stock market's gonna go down we're
headed for this huge recession the banks
are a mess you know their disaster
Fannie and Freddie are gonna go bankrupt
I was saying this stuff and everybody
was laughing at me but they kept
inviting me back on because you know I
guess they enjoyed it or who's good
ratings but then when everything that I
had been forecasted came true
people started to notice me I started
getting you know following on the
internet somebody made a montage of a
bunch of my interviews my and we call
the peter schiff was right and that
ended up getting a couple of million
views back when a couple of million
views was a lot of views for a youtube
video it's not as big deal anymore but
back then in 2009 there was a lot it was
a lot of views and and so you know I
wrote a few more books you know I got
more popular but then interestingly
enough the the mainstream media kind of
forgot about me you know they stopped
inviting me on and so I lost a lot of
that access that I had to like develop
my own access through the internet you
know I had a failed campaign for a
Senate in Connecticut in 2010 I had a
radio show that I did daily two hours a
day for a few years that I eventually
stopped doing because I just didn't have
the time to do and I started doing the
podcast a Peter Schiff show podcast
where I just record those you know
usually a couple of week you know when I
have time to do them but you know I've
got a pretty good following on the
internet now and you know on social
media but my main business is
asset management so I grew Euro Pacific
Capital I eventually started ship gold
which was your Pacific precious metals
that became chief gold
I partnered up with some guys in Canada
and we started your Pacific Canada which
has been read Knight renamed national on
global partners I started your Pacific
asset management which is now operating
here in Puerto Rico which is where I
live
I started euro Pacific Bank which is
also relocated here in Puerto Rico and
so those two businesses are running out
of Puerto Rico the asset management
company in the bank and so mainly I'm
you know in the investment advisor
business but you know I still you know
do a lot on social media to try to
advocate for what I believe in which is
free market capitalism limited
government sound money and I'm a critic
of politicians on both sides of the
aisle because it seems that nobody is
doing it right all right I got a lot of
questions but you've done a whole bunch
of life where'd the name Euro Pacific
come from well you know when I name the
company that I was focusing on a lot of
these foreign stocks so I wanted to have
kind of like a you know an international
sound I was on the Pacific I was on the
west coast and so it just seemed like
you know the euro the euro currency was
just you know starting and it was like
you're always seem like a popular word
so I just came up with euro euro pacific
capital as the name of the company got
it and then you know it seemed that you
were able to kind of call out the the
tech bubble maybe didn't tie it
perfectly but but for the most part said
hey this is overheated and then again
kind of late 2000s what were some of the
signals that you saw that really kind of
either identified those bubbles or were
the the main drivers as to why you
thought hey you know right now is not a
great time and they're likely to go down
and from an economy standpoint in the
short term at all well the tech bubble I
mean that went to me was very obvious I
mean the valuations that were being
assigned to these companies I mean I
remember Yahoo at the time was I used to
use this as a
example to my prospects and clients the
value of Yahoo alone that one company
was worth more than every company in New
Zealand as a country like you could buy
the entire New Zealand stock market and
it would be cheaper than buying Yahoo
and to me that seemed like look I can
buy this whole country or I could buy
Yahoo and so you know and I looked at a
lot of these companies that were making
no profits and I couldn't see how they
would ever make a profit but most people
didn't care I mean it was just all a
bubble and I was able to see that
attitude and and so the same thing
happened during the real estate bubble
as I was watching people buy houses and
flip houses and I was a renter I was
even subleasing some space
to mortgage brokers that I could see
firsthand how they were a dock you know
you know dumbing up applications and
they were you know basically
fraudulently changing people's incomes
and things like that and to try to get
them to qualify it to get a mortgage
refinanced and I can see the the
insanity going on I was in Southern
California and so real estate prices
were going up a lot and I knew the Fed
was behind both balls because I could
you know see the monetary policy that
was being pursued at the time and you
know I'm a student of history I know how
central bank's inflate bubbles and I
know what happens when when they pop but
yeah you know one thing I wanted to
mention the other this is an interesting
anecdote we talked about your capital so
when I name the company your pacific
capital my tagline was there's always a
bull market somewhere because there's
always a bull market somewhere and I did
that because at the time I did it you
know early on you know the US was not
doing well and all these foreign markets
were and so that was my tagline and then
I did a an interview with Jim Cramer way
back when this is before he even had a
show and he interviewed me and he liked
my tagline so he stole it from me
because he didn't start using it until
after he interviewed me and we were on
my website and he saw you know because
there's always a bull market somewhere
and they basically just took it and
adopted it for himself but but I had it
first all right so what well when you
look at these bubbles in terms
of kind of how we're outlook on the
market is would you consider yourself
like a perma bear or there are times
where you're also saying hey look you
know things are very undervalued and
we're about to enter a bull market you
kind of start preaching the the long
argument of markets as well yeah you
know people kind of look at me as a
perma bear but I'm you know I'm really
not because if you look at what I was
saying like what when I was bearish on
the US stock market during the.com
bubble and I was right about that the
market the market collapsed not quite as
much as I expected but that was because
the Fed did more than I expected I
didn't expect the Fed to take rates but
1% but when they did right I became
bullish on the US stock market 2001-2002
timeframe but I didn't recommend that
anybody invest in it I said look the Fed
is printing all this money so they're
gonna reflate stock prices but it's also
gonna cause the dollar to go down and so
it's better to invest internationally
buy foreign stocks buy commodities buy
bold and that advice was was very
prescient because we made a lot more
money during those years 2003 2004 2005
by being along global equities instead
of US equities I was not telling people
to shorten US stocks I just probably
have better returns in foreign stocks
and gold stocks and I was right about
that
where the US market surprised me was its
recent outperformance the outperformance
maybe in 2013 14 15 during those years
because when I was forecasting the
bursting of the housing bubble and you
know the Great Recession that would
follow in the financial crisis I assumed
that the world would figure it out after
that and that we would have a bigger
relative bear market in u.s. assets
relative to foreign assets I thought the
dollar would continue to lose value but
that didn't happen because you know you
had this big rally in the dollar and
everybody became even more convinced
that the US was you know in great shape
they believed the Fed they believed Ben
bernanke when he was out there saying
we're gonna normalize interest rates
we're gonna shrink our balance sheet
everybody believed him I mean I knew
that he was lying but the markets
believed him and so you had this rush
back into US assets and US stocks ended
up outperforming for a number of years
but but I still think that um ultimately
could be proven right on this forecast
because all these years that we were
able to kick the can down the road
the real fundamentals of the US economy
have gotten much worse the US economy
today is in much worse shape than it was
in a eight or nineteen ninety nine and
the crisis that were heading towards is
going to be far greater than what we
experienced in 2008 and rather than the
dollar rallying as a result of the
crisis I think the dollar is going to be
the crisis and then you know Bob's US
Treasury bonds I think it's gonna be a
currency crisis and a sovereign debt
crisis you know whether or not in the
stock market collapses relative you know
in dollar terms it's hard to say I think
it's gonna go down but I think the real
declines are gonna be measured relative
to gold or other assets that you can own
because when the Fed creates a lot of
money and money loses value when you're
trying to measure stock prices in terms
of a dollar that's also losing value
it's a moving target you know so I I'm
telling people by things that I think
they're gonna go up more than the US
stock market when the dollar goes down
got it and so we before we get to kind
of the impending crisis and some of the
things that you think people should be
doing what's up with the Senate run I
didn't know that well what was the
thought process there well you know
there really wasn't much of a thought
process into it I got drafted into it
because you know as I got popular in
2009 and I kind of developed an online
following a lot of people wanted me to
run for Senate and one of the reasons
was that Christopher Dodd was the
incumbent Democratic senator from
Connecticut and he was one of the big
defenders of Fannie and Freddie he was
saying how Salomon solvent they were and
how they were in great shape at the same
time he was saying that I was saying
they were insolvent in going bankrupt so
it seemed like a good kind
Trask you know the guy that defended
Fanny and said they were great Bruce is
the guy that called them out and said
they were gonna go bankrupt and but and
so the people wanted me to run for
Senate to run against Dodd
but anyway what ended up happening was
Dodd decided not to run for re-election
and so he wasn't even a factor but the
minute da dropped out right all of a
sudden other Republicans came in and so
it screwed up my chances if Dodd had
stayed in I don't think Linda McMahon
wouldn't come into the race because what
made Linda McMahon think she could win
was the fact that Dodd was stepping down
and now it was an open seat and so this
guy think Blumenthal was coming into it
been Attorney General and so Liv has
spent fifty million dollars in the
primary or in a know she spent 30
million in the primary 50 million total
but she spent 30 million against me I
only spent three and a half million and
I'm really know that was my money or a
little over a million the rest of it two
and a half million I got from donations
it's mostly small donations around the
country but she spent so much money that
I you know and she got a lot more media
than I did free media a lot of the
median Connecticut
decided not to cover me you know and and
the inner thing was in the polls all the
polls like even going into the election
I was holding it like 3 percent 4
percent I got 23 percent of the vote
Linda got you know like 45 and then or
50 and then there was another guy that
got you know about the same speed maybe
a little more skyrocketed so we've been
a congressman for 20 years in
Connecticut he was uh he was the
establishment Republican and then Linda
kind of stole my fire as the outside or
business person but you know a lot of
people were telling me that the reason
they didn't vote for me is because they
didn't think I had a chance because I
was so low in the polls but I actually
got 23 percent of the vote and so you
know it's possible that you know had the
poll open more accurate if people might
have been a little bit more encouraged
and you know there was only one debate
we had one debate early on and I I won
that debate every newspaper said I won
that debate and after that debate Linda
refused to have any more debates so I
lost the opportunity to debate Linda
McMahon because after the first one
not that many people saw she refuses to
bathe me again so I you know you went to
babe oh yeah this is this is the other
worst part about this is whether said
the Republicans didn't be in Connecticut
so we went to the convention in
Connecticut and you know you have to get
nominated and every year except my year
the nominees are allowed to give a
speech right to the convention hey this
is who I am this is why you should
nominate me so Linda McMahon Lobby and
she got them to change that so that
nobody was allowed to give a speech
because she didn't want people to hear
me talk she knows I'm a good speaker so
they changed it so that you could just
submit a five-minute video so instead of
addressing the convention we were only
allowed to submit a five-minute video so
leave this video play first she had her
five minute video then Rob Simmons video
played and then we came to play my video
the vigil equipment broke and so my
video didn't play so not only could I
not get to address the convention I
didn't even get to play my video
coincidentally it happened to break down
just in time for for my video and then I
ended up you know just barely missing I
didn't quite get enough votes because
Linda had her people out there you know
you know spreading rumors about me to
try to make sure I didn't get enough
seat enough votes to get on a ballot so
then I had to spend another 150 grand
and I became the first person in
Connecticut to ever petition his way
onto a nationwide ballot and I ended up
getting on the ballot in the Republican
nomination that year but again there's a
complete waste of money because yeah I
ended up that didn't go anywhere that
was kind of the end of my political
career it kind of started though with
Ron Paul I was an economic adviser to
his presidential campaign in in 2008 and
he was built you know he was the only
guy that was running in oh wait that was
critical the Fed and that understood the
bubble you know yeah for sure and so
let's talk a little bit you're a huge
proponent of gold and obviously have the
asset management business etc maybe talk
to us just kind of about your philosophy
around asset management and personal
finance and then how you look at
something like gold and how that fits
into
into that portfolio construction yeah
well you know I look at gold has money
and and so it's if you want to just have
some dry powder if you want to have a
liquidity rather than just considering
well I can keep dollars or I can keep
euros or I can keep yen what about whole
I mean gold is the real deal is actual
money all these currencies are money
substitutes of course when they were
legitimate currencies they were backed
by gold and it was the gold backing that
gave them their value but once
governments went off the gold standard
you know then they became fiat and and
so they're you know they don't have any
any real value they they have you know
market value and they have the value of
being legal tender and they have the
value that you know there used it as a
medium of exchange and that their
accepted and payment of taxes and stuff
like that but they don't have the real
value that gold has and so if you really
want to just not invest in stocks
because you think they're expensive or
not invest in bonds or not invest in
real estate you want to just keep some
savings
I think gold is a much better vehicle to
save than any of these fiat currencies
and if you go back over time that is the
case now if you can get a high enough
interest on your fiat currency that
interest may be able to confiscate
confiscate you or compensate you for the
loss of purchasing power that you're
gonna get on an annual basis because
they keep printing more money but now
when you have interest rates so low I
mean most people don't get any interest
at all I mean you got negative interest
rates in some cases so the argument for
holding gold even over Swiss francs now
right where you have negative rates has
never been stronger
so that's the i-team's you're gonna you
know you want to keep some dry powder
you should buy gold but you know I think
gold is underpriced though given how
much money has been created over the
last decade or two and how much more
money is gonna be created to try to keep
these bubbles from deflating the price
of gold should be much higher and it
would be much higher if more people
understood this then and over time
they're gonna figure it out and the
price is going to go much higher but in
the meantime
people who figured out early should be
loading up but I think the real profit
potential if you want to make a lot of
money off the increase in the price of
gold not just preserve your wealth the
gold stocks I think are a incredible
opportunity I think there's a lot of
small stocks of a good book 10 X 20 X 50
X maybe even 100 X by the end of this
bull market and so for the speculators
you really want to try to you know
strike it rich you know in the gold rush
they should be looking at gold mining
stocks I know we we have a separately
managed accounts of mine stocks and we
also have a bull fund that your Pacific
gold fund EP GFX is the symbol on my
gold fund and yes it's speculative I
mean most of the money we manage is not
in gold stocks it's a more conservative
dividend paying foreign stocks but for
the people who really want to bet big
that I'm right on gold if I am right
that's gonna be the big payoff
like I you know I did the subprime short
and we made good money shorting the
subprime market I think the payoff on
long Bowl socks is actually gonna be
bigger than the subprime sure what's
your take on Bitcoin I know that you're
a huge detractor give us kind of
high-level philosophically what's why
are you so bearish on yeah well you know
the Fed created the dot-com bubble the
Fed created the housing bubble and the
Fed created a Bitcoin bubble you know
maybe not exactly the same way but I
think Bitcoin started out as kind of a
reaction to all the monetary policy
mistakes that the Fed had made and
people were looking out for an
alternative and Bitcoin came on the
scene and you know initially you know
there was a libertarian community a hard
money community that was playing around
with it you know I found out about it
early on and you know it's just kind of
dismissed it because my initial read on
it was well what's the stop somebody
else from coming up with another
cryptocurrency which of course nothing
did there's thousands of them now and I
didn't see the intrinsic value in it but
I also didn't see that the bulb
potential I mean I really didn't think
it would grow to the scale that it did
otherwise
I could have thrown some money at it as
a flier but I initially kind of
dismissed it because of the properties
that it didn't have right and and of
course then you know when it all of a
sudden it came on the scene and went up
to a thousand and I remember when that
happened and all of a sudden you know
people started talking about it and it
you know they mentioned it on CNBC and
it was there and I think what really
kind of breathed life into it is once
gold kind of peaked out at nineteen
hundred and silver peaked out at fifty
you have his despair market that went on
in the precious metals pretty vicious
you know correction for a number of
years and that frustrated a lot of you
know people that would be buying gold
and silver and all of a sudden they saw
a big coin kind of going up and gold and
silver were going down and I think that
created some initial demand but all of a
sudden they took on you know these
bubble characteristics I'm we don't they
didn't pull back you know it got back
down at two hundred three hundred it
stayed there for a couple of years and I
actually you know thought about maybe I
should buy some just you know just as a
speculation but I just couldn't convince
myself to pay two or three hundred
dollars for something that I didn't want
to buy a $20 you know fundamentally I
didn't see any difference in it and then
you know the bubble really went crazy
when it went up to 20,000 and that's
what I think the whole mania peaked and
you had everybody buying it people were
calling me up wanting to buy it I had
clients calling me up with Bitcoin was
15,000 or wanting to put their whole
IRAs in the Bitcoin I mean nobody ever
called me to buy a Bitcoin until that
point I mean I talked about it and I
said I you know I didn't think it was
gonna work his money and I still don't
think it's gonna work his money but the
bubble it really was a frenzy and the
old I talk to people now who were kind
of in Bitcoin and just kind of committed
to it's like all into and mentally they
own a bunch of it they to me it's
exactly like when I was talking to
people about real estate in 2005 and
2006 my house is never gonna go down
it's always good to go off you're a fool
for renting you know you're wasting your
money
I mean people were completely into this
they thought there was no way there else
they
to go down and the same stuff you know I
talked to people until I was blue in the
face about the dot-com stocks that
ultimately a lot of them most of them
went bankrupt but I remember the
attitudes that people had about their
favorite Comstock even if they
acknowledge that other stocks could
class the ones that they owned we're
never gonna go down I mean so people
have a certain attitude that they assume
when they're trapped in the bubble and
how it influences their behavior and
their way of thinking and I see all of
those characteristics maybe even
stronger when it comes to the people who
are in Bitcoin but I just think this is
another big bubble it's gonna pop
personally I think the high is in for
this bubble I think that spike up to
20,000 at the end of 2017 around the
launch of the Bitcoin futures and all
that hysteria I think that was it and I
think now it's a question of the air
coming out you know we have these sucker
rallies you know bull markets the bear
markets fall asleep of hope you know you
have rallies people get excited oh it's
going to 20,000 sculling 50,000 but I
think the smart money is just trying to
get out you know and I think it's at
this point you don't want to be the bad
holder you know so let's go through kind
of first from a macro standpoint right
I'm going to put what coin and gold in
the same bucket for the moment I know
you don't want to agree to that but
let's just put it in it's a bucket and
say the macro environment that we're in
today there's a lot to be concerned
about right I think there's a lot of
what I'll call kind of warm bells going
off and earlier we're talking about kind
of holding crisis around the currency
crisis the sovereign debt bonds etc
first let's just talk about why you
think people should be looking at this
bucket whether they'd scold Bitcoin
whatever it is due to that macro
environment and then we can get into you
know talking through the differences
between Bitcoin and gold but just from a
macro standpoint like what are the
signals that you're seeing that has you
kind of ringing those alarm bells and
saying hey people should be paying
attention again well you know
when you get to a point now where you've
got negative interest rates right you
know that we're kind of at the end of
the rope here because what these central
banks have been doing in order to avoid
the political pain of having to address
economic imbalances having to cut
government spending right having to
allow debt to be restructured and
investors to lose money they keep
kicking the can down the road by
lowering and lowering interest rates but
the the biggest problem in the global
economy is that interest rates are too
low that is the problem that's not the
solution
that is the problem and the longer they
keep raised so the lower they keep them
the bigger the problem gets it's that
you know but every time they get a new
basically you know injection of cheaper
money they you know there's like a high
right all of a sudden you know oh it's
like if you're an individual and you're
you know broke you've run up a bunch of
credit card debt and you're about to go
bankrupt and all of a sudden somebody
sent you another credit card within you
know another $10,000 limit oh great now
I can go on all of a sudden you go out
and start spending money yet because you
got another credit card well all that
means is that you're gonna end up with
even more debt than you had before your
problems haven't been solved you've just
been able to kick them the can down the
road because now you can go deeper into
debt but ultimately you end up with even
bigger problem than when you have before
because now you owe even more money and
so this is what the central bank is
doing we have too much debt and whenever
that debt becomes a problem like it did
in 2008 they just would mean even more
debt we need to have an even bigger
bubble and now we don't have to deal
with the problems of this smaller bubble
and so they keep lowering interest rates
but as they do that they're interfering
with the real economy what the real
economy wants is higher interest rates
they want more savings more capital
investment less spending less
speculation we need to have a
restructuring and as the central bank's
resist that we're just getting become is
getting sicker right it's like if you're
you know you're high on drugs and every
time you stop taking drugs and now you
start going through withdrawal they just
give you more drugs so you know the
drugs
get out of your system and you know you
never you know you never cure your habit
because you keep taking drugs every time
if the effect starts to wear off but at
some point right they keep lowering
rates lowering rates lowering rates and
now they get to zero and now they still
want to lower rates and they don't
realize that the lower rates the problem
it's like I've used the analogy to a
medieval you know barbers doctors
whatever they used to call them with
bloodletting right they'd have a patient
who is sick and the solution is oh oh we
need to take some blood out we need to
bleed them let's get leeches and take
you know they and then they take blood
out and then the patient gets sicker and
as well I guess we didn't take out
enough blood let's take out some more
and so I guess eventually you take out
enough blood and the patient dies they
don't realize that the problem that
their cure is actually making a patient
sicker and that's what the central banks
were doing when they cut rates and they
print money they're actually making the
underlying economy sicker even though it
doesn't look sicker because they're just
measuring you know the spending that
goes on and they're ignoring the debt
that's behind it so I think we're at the
point now where we're gonna overdose on
all this printing I think that when this
bubble pops when the US economy goes
back into recession the amount of money
that they're gonna have to print right I
gonna is gonna crash the dollar I think
inflation which you know the way the
government measures it is even you know
running at 3% a little over 2% the way
they measure it which is not very
accurate by design but I think that
inflation rate is going to continue to
head higher 3% 4% 5% and people are
going to lose confidence in holding on
to dollars because if the inflation rate
is 4 or 5% compounding and you're
getting into 0% interest or whatever on
your dollars you know that's a one-way
ticket to a disaster and people are
gonna want to cast that in they're gonna
want to jump that ship before it sinks
and were they going to go right I mean
it's gonna be a currency crisis and I
think inflation is gonna break out all
around the world and you know a lot of
these central banks have been hiding
behind low inflation they've been saying
no inflation is not high enough
we need more inflation and that's been a
justification for this monetary policy
but you know low inflation is not a
problem I mean zero inflation is better
than low inflation and following prices
are better than prices that are rising
slightly but the central banks are
pretending that we can't have economic
growth unless prices rise by two percent
a year or more which is a bunch of
self-serving nonsense but at some point
the inflation is going to be high enough
that they can no longer you know pretend
that the problem is there's not enough
inflation and now they're forced to
raise rates but that's what it is to fan
because now the debt bubble pops and now
you have to pay the piper and I think
you know the country that's got the
biggest tab is gonna be the United
States because we've basically benefited
the boats from this monetary system this
fiat based system because we're the
center of it were the reserve currency
and Americans have been able to live
beyond their means more than any other
nation we've been able to consume
without producing we've been able to
borrow without savings that we've built
an entire economy based on the
perpetuation of this continuing that we
can run trade deficits forever and
budget that forever and keep having low
interest rates and consumer prices that
aren't going up and when that whole
thing changes there's a whole monetary
crisis and you know I think that the
only way out of the monetary crisis is
for central banks to go back to gold I
mean I think the United States convinced
the world after Second World War to
abandon the gold standard and to adopt a
dollar standard mainly because the
dollar was not only backed by gold but
convertible into gold and we had all the
gold we were the most powerful economy
we had the biggest trade surpluses we
were the biggest creditor nation and so
the world trusted us and then we screwed
him over and you know we basically
default about our promise in 1971 and
we've been on this Fiat system ever
since I think the only thing that will
work is for the world to go back to gold
right some people think well you know
the dollar is never gonna lose its
reserve status because you know what
currency is the world gonna go
they're not going to take the euro
they're not going to take the end I
agree those are not viable alternatives
but what is the most viable alternative
is that the world simply goes back to
what the reserve was prior to the dollar
and that was goal got it what why do you
think that they can't just continue to
print money and manipulate the economy
like what stops them from just forever
kicking the can down the road even
though structurally you know I agree
with you that it's absolutely sanity
like what stops them from just doing it
forever well you know nothing that can't
go on forever will right just like the
housing bubble didn't go on forever the
dot-com bubble this bubble won't go on
forever because what is allowing it to
happen is you know pretending that it's
all temporary right when when the Fed
did chewie the secret to it not
producing a crisis was the Fed telling
everybody this is temporary this is an
emergency and when the emergency is over
we're going to reverse process that
reverse the process and normalize only
interest rates and shrink our balance
sheet rates are not going to be down
here and so the markets believed that
this was temporary and the Fed always
says look if inflation should ever rare
is up you know we can fight it really
easy right we should just jack up
interest rates which is a lie they can't
do that and they won't do that but as
long as the markets believe that the Fed
has this under control that they can
shrink their balance sheet they could
normalize rates they could fight
inflation well then maybe it goes on but
at some point the the Fed is gonna have
to put up or shut up because inflation
is going to pick up right and they're
not gonna be able to fight it in fact
the economy started to turn down and now
we're at the Fed do the Fed called off
rate hikes they've now cut rates twice
they're about to cut them again they
stop shrinking their balance sheet
they're now back to quantitative easing
they're not admitting that it's QE but
they're actually expanding their balance
sheet faster now than they were when
they were doing QE so of course they're
doing QE so the Fed has already
basically cobbled its pants down and I
don't think it's gonna take much more
and of course if Donald Trump isn't
reelected if we get one of these
Socialists Elizabeth Warren
Sanders and they want Medicare for all
and free health care and all this stuff
I mean that's gonna blow the bank I mean
you're gonna be talking about three to
four trillion dollar year deficits these
are impossible to finance I mean we're
already having a problem financing the
deficits that's why the Fed is back
doing QE there's just not enough private
demand for all the debt that the
government is selling what's your take
in terms of the presidential election as
you know we're facing this kind of macro
situation
does anybody have a solid plan or are
they all completely understands it no no
no one has a plan I mean you know no
one's even talking about the debt and
you watch these Democratic debates
there's never even a question on the bed
nobody you know what even mentions that
and you know so I guess it's probably
not even gonna be an issue in the
campaign right even though Donald Trump
is the biggest deficit spender every is
bigger than Obama it's not even to be
called in you know as an issue but never
everybody has a plan to make government
bigger you know they want more members
like look at these idiots you know an
easy example is the college student loan
crisis I mean one of the things that all
these Democrats want to talk about is
how we have this huge through his loan
problem and we need to forgive the loans
and make College free but all these
Democrats don't understand that the only
reason we have a student loan problem is
because of the government the only
reason that there are student loans is
because of the government without the
governor clipping those student loans
the government made the loans the
government guarantee the loans and
before the government guaranteed student
loans College wasn't expensive you
didn't need to borrow money to go to
college before the government started
that loan program people either their
parents paid for college or they had
summer jobs like my dad and they worked
their way through college it wasn't hard
to do right but now it's impossible to
do because the government has made
college so expensive because of the
moral hazards associated with student
loans but now instead of you know
getting government out of education so
the costs can go down they want to make
it free so the cost will be even higher
right so they they have no clue
all these Socialists they
look at these problems that were caused
by socialist programs that have been
mixed into a capitalist economy and
instead of recognizing that it's the
socialism that's been mixed in with
capitalist and that's the problem they
want to blame it on capitalism and they
want even more socialism which again
it's like the same thing to central
banks do they keep interest rates
artificially low they screw up the
economy and then they think oh we just
need to make interest rates even lower
we have to print even more money and now
they swept the economy even more and so
the solution is let's do more of the
same
so if President Peter Schiff ever
happened what would you do Lucien you
hit on a little bit of it already but
like what's the the perfect plan
well you know there is no perfect plan
right I mean it's you know we we're
gonna have to have a severe recession if
we're ever going to you know how to
build a viable economy right Trump
campaigned about making America great
again you know I would love to make
America great again but I recognize that
the road to greatness is a very bumpy
road and and so if we do all the right
stuff you know it's gonna be difficult
initially for a lot of people just like
you know I mentioned it drugs in our
analogy you know if you're a drug addict
and you want to kick the habit and
you're gonna go to rehab
I mean rehab it's you know it's not like
going to Club Med I mean it's not it's
not fun that's why it's hard for people
to go there but if you do it and then
you do the right thing you can improve
your life so we have to go on a monetary
rehab Americans have to stop spending
and buy and stuff we have to start
saving again we have to start making
capital investments we have to start
this mantling a lot of the government
you know we have to start getting rid of
agencies and departments making
government much much smaller we need to
return a lot of government workers to
the private sector so they can work
productively we've got to repeal a lot
of these labor laws minimum wage laws
and occupational licensing laws and all
these discrimination laws that drive up
the cost of employment you know this
we're gonna need to put people to work
productively it'd be great if we can get
rid of the income tax and the Social
Security tax we can do that if we really
shrink government but I don't think
there's any way out of this that
includes paying off the debt so we have
to default on a lot of the debt I mean
just like you know Argentina or other
trees that have taken on too much debt
America has to recognize we have too
much debt we can't pay it off and we
have to restructure it and it's not just
the creditors who are going to take a
haircut we need to say the same thing to
people on tour expecting Social Security
and Medicare you're just not gonna get
what you were promised you know you're
gonna get less than you'll promise we
need to find ways of phasing these
programs out and means testing them on
the way out but you know we have to
restore the Freedom and the Liberty that
you know a century of big government has
destroyed we have to make America what
it used to be which is a bastion of free
market capitalism individual liberty
sound money if we do that you know we
can achieve tremendous prosperity you
know but what the what they're selling
us now is a snake oil it's just
socialism what do you think in terms of
that default situation like what does
that look like right if we actually did
say okay we're gonna we're just gonna
kind of bite the bullet and we're gonna
default it what happens in that scenario
well I mean the bondholders don't get
back you know 100 cents on the dollar
but the important thing to recognize is
we're defaulting no matter what right
because honest repayment is impossible
right it is impossible to repay the debt
right and so the only question is how do
we default on it do we do it the honest
way which is the way I think it should
be done or are we gonna do it too
dishonest way which is the way it's
probably gonna be done and that's
through inflation right you just print
money right so you don't default on your
obligations you print up all the money
and you give everybody the money they're
owed but what happens under that
scenario is the money doesn't buy very
much so the creditors lose out either
way either they don't get back all of
their dollars or they get back all their
dollars but they don't get back their
purchasing power and under my scenario
of an honest default
I think the creditors will end up better
off I think they'll actually have more
purchasing power if they get paid 20
cents on the dollar or whatever versus
inflation where they may be at 2 cents
on the dollar right we have AI for
inflation so you know my scenario would
be better and it would be much better
for the economy because the worst thing
for the economy is to destroy
cards I mean that's much worse than
defaulting on debt do you think we're
headed there like is the currency
screwed either way
look the currency is going down the only
question is you know is it going to go
to zero or how close is it gonna get but
the dollar is going down I mean all fiat
currencies are gonna go down I mean
they're designed to go down in fact if
you listen to what these central bankers
are saying they want their currency to
lose 2% of its value every year well
after 50 years that's almost everything
all right so you know if you lose 2% of
your value every year I mean you're you
know you're going way down but you know
the thing is if the if the central
bankers are telling you they want the
currency to lose 2% its gonna lose a lot
more than that because not too long ago
the central bankers were promising price
stability they weren't saying that they
wanted prices to go up 2% a year they
said their goal was to have stable
prices well where their goal was stable
prices we still had rising prices so now
that their goal is rising prices
imagine how much faster prices are gonna
rise when their goal is to make them
rise so you know they're gonna way
overshoot this this so-called 2% number
so we know that these currencies are
gonna go down they're gonna go way down
and the question is how fast and do you
go down with the ship
or do you do something about it do you
abandon ship and that's what I've done
right I mean I've gotten off the Titanic
and I'm in a lifeboat now I think people
who are coming to this conclusion but
who are going into Bitcoin see I think
they're jumping out of a frying pan into
the fire now I think that that Fiat
crypto currencies like Bitcoin could end
up zeroing out a long before the dollar
does or close close to it so let's talk
about gold and Bitcoin right as this
macro situation plays out your belief is
that we would return back to like a gold
standard or are we gonna wear gold coins
in our pocket like what do you actually
think would be the solution and how gold
plays into that
well Gold just needs to be the reserve
that anchors currencies so just like
central banks now have reserves of
foreign exchange most central banks also
have gold as a portion of their
serves they just need to increase the
gold component of those reserves and
then fix their currency to the price of
all at some convertible rate I mean so
yeah when we were on a gold standard it
didn't mean that you had to walk around
with the gold coins although some people
did but we still had paper money except
the paper money was backed by gold right
you can get the gold if you wanted to
but you can also transact in the paper
and you know today with the you know the
internet and digital I mean you can
transact in gold digitally it's not hard
to do I mean you take a company like ol
bunny that I'm associated with and you
know you can have a gold money account
but I can transfer you know any amount
of gold from my account to anybody
else's account I don't have to even give
them a whole outs I can give them a gram
of gold right so I can I can you know
pay for a small transaction instantly
and transfer ownership of gold so people
don't have to walk around with gold in
order to be on a gold standard you just
have to have gold that's backing up the
transaction if you have that gold as you
know a monetary reference because the
reason that we have gold is because gold
replaced Barbara and what barter is is
you know you're exchanging one product
of value for another product of value
gold or money was an invention that
improved commerce because it was the
commodity that would could be accepted
in exchange for all commodities so that
you know if if I was a chair maker and I
wanted to buy a stake I didn't have to
find a butcher who wanted one of my
chairs right now that could take forever
but I know hey I can give them butchered
Bowl because he can use gold to buy
whatever he wants everybody will accept
bold as the one commodity that is the
most liquid of all commodities so it
became money so that you have to have
money has to be an actual commodity it
just can't be something that's made up
out of thin air it has to actually be a
good that has value because that's what
you're doing when you're buying and
selling something and you're paying in
bold you're paying in real value you're
getting you're getting goods or services
of value and you're paying with it with
with something of value that's the
problem with Bitcoin if I'm transacting
for Bitcoin I'm giving somebody
you either goods or services and they're
giving me nothing they're giving me
visual nothing you're not giving me
anything that I can use you know I keep
challenging the Bitcoin people because
they keep telling me that you know gold
has no uses and Bitcoin does it's the
opposite
Gold has all sorts of uses Bitcoin has
none I mean you can use Bitcoin as a
medium of exchange it's not a great
medium of exchange but you can use it
but you have to have an alternative use
right I mean because let's say the price
of Bitcoin just collapses because people
you know it's all about what people
believe but people think it's gonna be
worth something they're willing to buy
it but there's nothing that would
prevent it from imploding because all of
a sudden people stop believing it's
gonna go up and they no longer want to
buy it
that can't happen with gold because even
if even if investors decided they didn't
want any gold for whatever reason I
don't think they would decide that but
let's say the price and Bowl crashed and
let's say it went down with $500 an
ounce from 15 on its pile of think it's
gonna happen but let's say that happened
because investors just stopped believing
in it well there would be tremendous
demand from industry from jewelry to buy
up that goal I mean you know there's
there's a lot of useless for bold people
would look at that oh my god there's a
sale on all but we loaded up I can buy
some I can you know get some gold and
you know there's a lot of areas where
gold would be used but it's too
expensive so they use copper or some
other metal that isn't as good but
doesn't cost as much but as the price of
gold comes down
more people will decide the use goal
instead of lesser metals and of course
nobody's gonna buy gold at $500 because
it costs to have a lot more than that to
mine it so there's no more supply coming
on the market and eventually the price
would come back up because there's real
demand but in Bitcoin there is no real
buyer for Bitcoin there is no user of
Bitcoin it's all speculation
so if speculators no longer want to buy
it because now they think it's going
down and not going up to the thing
implodes and the whole it's all over and
so because of that I mean you can't
store any real value in Bitcoin because
any day you wake up and could be gone
because it's all an illusion it's all
just on paper yeah but but so let's
let's go through that though right I
think that there is an argument
that many many other assets that you own
outside of currencies have now become
digital and you can make the exact same
argument that tomorrow you could wake up
and they're gone but that doesn't mean
that they don't have value well what do
you mean give me an example well let's
take for example a music file
let's take US dollars right and let's
take a music file first of all so first
of all a music file the value that I get
from a music file is I can play the
music and I can listen to it and that
can entertain me I can sing along to it
I can dance to it I can create
atmosphere for you know a romantic
dinner or for a party so there's a use
to that file and of course if the file
gets destroyed I mean how much is the
file a dollar you know it's not there's
not a lot of monetary value there but
there is actual use to me right then
it's the Bitcoin I can't do anything
with Bitcoin I can't it can't entertain
me it can't it's not atmosphere right it
doesn't do anything it's not an actual
asset like the music you definitely do
something with it right because you can
do you can do anything you can look
after you you can't other than other
than exchange it to somebody else
you have to come up with a use case I
know I can give it to somebody I can
transfer it to somebody else if they
want it but I'm not talking about that
I'm talking about if I was sitting alone
right in my house with my Bitcoin what
can I do with it I can listen to the
music I can enjoy the music what can I
do with my big well so that there's a
couple of different things that you can
do one is you can store your wealth in
Bitcoin so you can hold on hold on you
can store wealth you can you transact
you also did you know that you could
actually put a message on to the Bitcoin
blockchain you could write an immutable
message okay so you're saying that the
value of Bitcoin is high it's like I can
send a message well I can send a message
on whatsapp I could send it and it cost
me nothing why would I have to buy an
expensive Bitcoin to send a message when
I can send a message for free on
whatsapp
it seems like a very expensive messaging
service if you're saying they're not use
a Bitcoin to send a message I'm not
arguing that that's what gives it value
but I'm saying that there that there's
multiple you came up with because when
you said I can't I can get I can
transact in that doesn't count and
saying they should store a value doesn't
count either as a use I'm saying it in
account because storing value is not the
use the use is what you can do with it
like the reason I store value in gold
right the reason you say Gold is
Explorer value is because if I have an
ounce of gold today there are a lot of
things that that bolt can be used for it
can be made into jewelry it can be put
into you know electronics it can be made
in used in dentistry there's all sorts
of things that it can be used for if I
don't if I take that gold and store it
for a hundred years you could still use
it for those things a hundred years from
now so the value of that mold is
preserved because bolt doesn't decay it
doesn't rot right it stays exactly the
same so everything I can do with my gold
today that value is stored for the
future well I can't do anything with bit
quality point Bitcoin today so if I
can't do anything with it today it
doesn't have any value that I can store
into the future what were you talking
about a store value for Bitcoin yes
people that bought Bitcoin years and
years ago for ten cents a dollar or a
hundred dollars they have more money now
if they want to cash out that's not a
store value what that means is what they
bought went up in market value because
somebody else now wants to buy it and is
willing to pay more so they have a
speculative gain on that asset it didn't
store any value because there was no
value but there was there is a
perception and so you had an increase
and you have the opportunity to sell at
a profit just like there were people who
bought Comstock's and they had the
opportunity sell for profit even though
the underlying companies had no real
value because they lost money and they
have no prospect of ever making money
but that didn't stop people on gambling
on them and so they did and so people
gambled on Bitcoin and if they're smart
they can cash out and they have a
profitable gamble but the people who are
buying what they're selling are the bad
holders because now they're gonna ride
the thing down
there was never any value there to begin
with it was just a perception and as
soon as that perception changes as soon
as people no longer believe the price is
going to keep going up then there's no
reason for anybody to own it and then
the price in close skirts girl want to
know who has the best URL crypto comm
that's right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal mother mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet Curto comm
is helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha
everybody got some electricity and Wi-Fi
all you got to do is go to coin mine
comm you buy a coin mine
it's like an Xbox or a Playstation that
helps you turn your electricity into
Bitcoin that's right you purchase it it
shows up at your doorstep you pull it
out of the box you plug it in connect to
your Wi-Fi five minutes or less you're
mining Bitcoin all you have to do is
control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just your update your coin mine consumer
mining made easy that's right go to coin
mine com tell them pom sent you and
thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly in
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compounds so you receive a 6.2 percent
APY which is very attractive given the
alternatives so you can actually take
your Bitcoin you can deposit it with
block Phi and get paid an interest rate
of 6% in return go check out block 5
comm slash pop again block 5 comm slash
pump to sign up and start earning
interest on your crypto today
part of this is Bitcoin is more scarce
and sounder money than gold no no I mean
a I mean he's scarce in that okay yes in
fear there's only 21 million bitcoins
right and assuming that makes it gold
right well look scarce look you know I
could get Peter a regional Peter Schiff
art it's more scarce than gold what is
that worth I mean there are a lot of
things that are scarce that don't
necessarily have value they have to be
scarce and they have to have use and be
valuable right because scarcely doesn't
mean anything if nobody wants right
obvious if you have and if nobody wants
any Bitcoin the fact there's 21 million
of them that's 21 million too many if
nobody wants but even if you agree that
no supercomputer or quantum computer is
gonna be able to you know crack this
counterfeit the bitcoins and even if you
forget about all the forks and the
Bitcoin cash and the Bitcoin gold and
what a bitcoin is the Bitcoin that even
if you just want to focus just on
Bitcoin and say ok there's 21 million of
them there are 3,000 other crypto
currencies that already exist that have
properties that are very similar to
Bitcoin some have properties that are
actually better than Bitcoin when it
comes to transactions and so since
Bitcoin doesn't offer anything that's
unique that other crypto currencies
don't have or can't improve upon then
what
Wyatt does anybody think if the scarcity
matters you know Bitcoin first started
right and and and they were people
trying to get me into it the whole idea
was it this was money this was a medium
of exchange this is you could buy a cup
of coffee with Bitcoin nobody was
talking about what's digital gold the
value was that it was it was great as a
media exchange well would it failed to
do that when it really didn't function
well to meet of exchange then they came
up with this alternative store that it's
digital Bowl that well
he's actually to use it for anything
they're just gonna store like they store
gold because gold is a use for anything
it's a bunch of nonsense this gold is
used for a lot of things Gold is not
worthless
Gold has a lot of value that's why
people own it that's why it's being
stored so but Bitcoin yes when they
created Bitcoin it was designed to mimic
gold it was a counterfeit of gold right
they make they represent it like a gold
colored coin even though it has no color
it has no substance a mined Bitcoin even
though you don't mind it if you solve a
math problem so they tried to make it
out like they were creating gold out of
nothing which you know but they're not
you're not creating gold you don't have
any actual goal that's why it's the
ultimate fool's gold all right so we'll
agree to disagree on on that last
statement but I at least established
that Bitcoin is more scarce than gold
but to your point it's it's only
important if there is demand for that
scarce asset right so I think that from
a structural standpoint that's correct
well how would you say there's a 20 it's
scarce than gold there's only 21 million
I mean but gold is not expressed in
millions I mean I know are there 21
million ounces of gold in the world I
don't think so that's a lot of think
that's a lot of houses but so you're
talking about you have to break you know
gold down I mean all the gold in the
world
that's ever been mine would fit inside
an Olympic sized swimming pool so that
seems pretty scarce to me although you
know I mean I think if you to in order
to maintain the Bitcoin network right
you see if Bitcoin is not just the
bitcoins because bitcoin is nothing but
all these computers all over the world
that are required to you know operate
the system and all the energy that is
required to be expended in order to
perpetuate the system so you know when
you throw all that together I mean you
know there's a lot more of that than
there is gold
all right we'll agree to disagree in
terms of sound money right why do you
think bitcoin is not sound money
well because money by definition needs
to be a commodity right and bitcoin is
not Bitcoin doesn't
to you in another CFTC says that it's a
commodity well they're just trying to
define it for regulatory purposes but
it's not a commodity like soybeans or a
commodity or like oil is a commodity or
like copper is a commodity it's not used
it means for all other commodities
there's actual demand for the commodity
it's used right if it's food it's
consumed if it's metal its fashioned
into something but bitcoin is not used
by anybody for anything so it is not
technically a commodity even if the t
CFC c wants to define it as a commodity
so it can regulate it and so it can you
know it don't you know apply that to it
but it's not really a commodity just
because the government wants that wants
to claim it is you know I mean to me
it's more like a fiat currency if it's
used as a medium machines because fiat
currency has no value either right it's
just a piece of paper and fundamentally
and ultimately all fiat currencies
historically have gone to zero and so
you know and so I think the same thing
would happen to the fiat currencies that
exist today it's just taking you know
longer and for it to happen but to me
Bitcoin is more of a fiat currency
Brenkus
a courtesy is not money a currency isn't
substitute for money you could use
currency instead of money but it's not
money right because money is a specific
type of commodity a currency is a medium
to exchange but that doesn't make it
money just because we use these words
interchangeably now doesn't mean that
that's what they are just like the
definition of inflation is an expansion
of the supply of money it's not crisis
going up but we now you know redefine
inflation to mean something that it
doesn't mean the same thing with money
and currency you know when you look at a
Federal Reserve Note that you have in
your hand it's its currency right it's a
note the money was the dollars that the
goal that used to back it up it's the
original Federal Reserve notes set on
them promise to pay will pay to the
bearer on demand you know ten dollars of
gold or you know twenty dollars of gold
so there was actual gold that was the
money right that that was legally what
money was was gold and but people used
substitutes like currency it
because it was easier to transact right
rather than take your bowl around you
left your gold and evolved with a
blacksmith or with a bank and you took a
banknote and you transact it in a money
substitute not the money itself but
court you know if you had to die if you
had a penny if you had a nickel that was
money right it was money because to his
metal nipa the copper was money that the
nickel was money it was a unit of money
right but that the paper bills were
substitutes for money because they were
easier to transact it and so to me
that's what bitcoin is like it's like a
fiat currency to the extent that you
could use it as a meaning exchange but
nobody really uses it as a medium
exchange the way they use dollars or
euros they just kind of speculated
people buy Bitcoin and they hope the
price goes up you know and that's and
that's why they own it because they
think they're gonna get rich I mean most
people today who own Bitcoin have
delusions of a hundred thousand a
million dollars a Bitcoin that's why
they don't want to sell that's why
they're hot one right forever because
they're gonna get rich well you know one
of these days you know somebody's gonna
want to move out of their parents
basement they're gonna have to sell some
big I donno we got there's a bunch of
stuff in there first of all are you
arguing that the only real money is
something that is metal
no I'm is over-salt was money in fact
the word salary comes from salt I mean
the Romans paid their soldiers and salt
cigarettes served as money of GIS after
World War Two because money is a
commodity that is being exchanged for
other commodities right that's what it
is
cattle has been used as money so all
sorts of things could be money it's just
in gold is a much better money right it
works a lot better and legally in the
United States what's money is gold and
silver really because that's what's in
the Constitution legally a sleeping
centre but any commodity could be money
it's just you know if it's if people use
it as a medium of exchange the world is
just a better form of money than other
commodities and have served as might
look the Indians use wampum sea shells
have been money right but paste pieces
of paper are not money
they are substitutes for money okay
right the paper itself doesn't have any
actual value it's not used for
anything seashells were used for things
they they adorn themselves with them
they make necklaces out of them no but
you know people are making necklaces out
of dollar bills
can you see a world where digital
commodities or digital assets when sort
of as money or do you think they can
serve as money so if somebody wants to
create a digital currency and they want
it back at my goal they want to back it
by silver they want to back it by copper
they want to back it by foil they want
to back it by whatever you can even back
it by you know a intangible assets you
get back you know get back and buy a
stock you can secure ties or digitize a
lot of things and people could decide
that it's gonna circulate as a medium of
exchange and you know and if it is
backed by a commodity right the
commodity itself would be served as
money so if I was going to pay you in in
gold but I was going to pay you in the
digital currency that was backed by gold
the digital currency would be the money
substitute but the gold would be the
money itself right just like banks
before the Federal Reserve you have
private banks that used to issue their
own currency that was backed by the goal
they had on the plaza and those notes
would circulate as you know as money
substitutes in the economy because
people knew that there was actually
money backing them up and so yeah you I
mean you could do that the main obstacle
to private enterprise today creating
viable digital currencies that were
backed by real money is see government's
hate this government's going leftist
governments want everybody using air
Fiat they have a monopoly on creating
fiat currency out of thin air and they
always governments like they run big
deficits and they want people using
their money they don't want people being
able to escape their system and also
they have all sorts of surveillance now
on everybody all these governments now
have draconian confiscatory levels of
taxes
and the way they keep everybody
compliant with these high taxes is
because they have records of what
everybody is spending their money on
but the minute if you can actually get
outside their surveillance if you can
transact
in money where they got were you're more
anonymous and that's a threat to big
government and you know and I watch
these hearings you know you know where
they think this is terrible
Libre or some other currencies or any
crypto currencies because they help
citizens evade a government oversight
that's a good thing you know we want to
be able to evade government oversight we
want to make it hard for the government
to tax us and to regulate us that's what
keeps us free you know the government
always wants to claim that oh it's about
terrorism it's about no it's not
you know there's old sayings about you
know people who give up who give up some
Liberty in order to achieve security
right they deserve neither liberty nor
security and they'll end up losing them
both I don't care if there's some
terrorist activity out there I'm not
going to give up my freedoms just to
potentially have less terrorism because
then you have to the threat is from the
government and and so but the government
you know the government doesn't want us
using real money they don't want us
escaping their air system they want us
all staying in their system so they can
tax us through inflation so they can
regulate us and so we have less ability
to resist their tyranny in their power
all right howhow do you think bitcoin
can go if you really believe it's going
to zero and it's not going to be
valuable right and you don't think that
it can be money you you said that
there's delusions of it going to these
really high numbers like what do you
think happens well look on anything
could happen right I mean if if people
decide not to sell Bitcoin right if
everybody that owns it decides you know
that they're not going to sell and then
people try to buy and there's no there's
no supply the price could go up right
and look you know it went up to 20,000
right does that mean it can go to 50,000
it can't go to 100,000 I mean it's
possible I just think that the odds of
that happening are are are low I mean
it's not impossible but it could have
but no matter how high it goes it's
ultimately gonna crash so and that I'm
confident of but can the bubble get even
bigger
sure could but you know I'd rather bet
rather than buy in Bitcoin at $8,500 and
thinking oh maybe it's gonna go to
85,000 I make 10 times my money just buy
some silver at 18 bucks
I mean that probably has a better chance
of going up tenfold I think that bitcoin
and it doesn't have any chance to go to
zero in fact I don't think there's that
much downside it's silver where there's
a lot of downside of course the same
thing applies to bold so and then gold
stocks I mean if you really want a
gamble on the breakdown of the Fiat
monetary system I think that you know
you're better off in mining gold mining
stocks then in Bitcoin and in fact I
don't even think Bitcoin is really a bet
against the dollar or the year or any of
the fiat currencies I really think it's
a bet against gold I think that bitcoin
is going to do better if gold really
gets weak if for some reason the price
of gold really starts to fall that I
think is probably more bullish for
Bitcoin then if we get weakness in a
dollar if we get strength in a price of
gold
I think that's ultimately a negative for
Bitcoin because I think that you know to
the extent that real world makes a
comeback and more people want to buy
real gold I think that will dampen the
enthusiasm for Bitcoin and other
alternatives to go what why do you think
it's a bet against gold right what may
in your opinion benefit from some of the
same macro events and end forces well
not really I think that if you look at
the way Bitcoin is being positioned and
being marketed you know particularly if
you look at the drop Gold campaign you
know but just in general that hey it's a
digital goal that's gonna eat into
Gold's market share this is what I hear
all would-be guys but people buy and all
the other people is like they take a
look at what Gold's market cap is and
hey if Bitcoin can capture X percent of
gold this is what it's worth so it's all
about taking market share away from gold
and and proving that it's better than
gold and so to that to the extent that
gold is succeeding then then there's
less of an argument that we need an
alternative to coal but I think if if
gold is can be shown as hey gold was
going down
bitcoin is going up look-see golden
bitcoin is working better so I think
that helps drive the narrative that a
bitcoin is a new goal and I think that's
what helped drive it for those years
where gold was in that bear market
correction and a lot of people were
getting frustrated that gold was going
down and they saw a Bitcoin going up and
people just you know jump on that on
that train and and I and I think you
know I think if you try to guess the
correlation although I'm not sure you
know you know if Bitcoin if you look out
on a daily basis and look at the price
of gold versus the price of Bitcoin you
know you know if it's you know how the
correlation is on any given day you know
whether it's correlated in a positive or
a negative way
because obviously you know most of the
time Bitcoin was going up because it
started so low you know it started that
penny is ten years ago and it kept going
up and up and up and up and up until you
know it we peaked out in you know at
20,000 but maybe even since then you
know how its acted since then if someone
is you know correlated it to gold on a
daily basis and so as you as you kind of
think through this like what what do you
think about Libra and the private
enterprises trying to create a version
of a digital currency right level is
that something that you think you spoke
a little bit earlier about how the
government want to happen but that
impact gold prices how does that impact
what corn in your opinion oh look I
think that competition would be very
healthy in you know in in alternatives
to what we have now and to the extent
that Lieber was able to get off the
ground I think it would be a good thing
you know I think that the government is
going to regulate it and maybe regulate
out of existence I mean depending on how
much regulation there's there I mean if
there was no mapping around at all it
would be very easy for any company to
come up with a cryptocurrency backed by
something would be very inexpensive be
very easy to do and then it would be as
simply about the companies having to
compete for trust and confidence because
ultimately when there is a digital
currency that's backed by something you
have to have
trust that the backing is good and so
you have to trust the company that is
promising that they're storing your goal
there ever is but I mean we trust
companies all the time I mean people buy
an insurance policy they buy life
insurance they trust that the insurance
company is gonna pay the claim when they
die right the years old the free market
is all about trusting counterparties and
reputation is important and companies
compete for a reputation and once you
have a reputation there is a value to
that reputation and a reason to want to
maintain it and so I think it would be
very good if we had a lot of privately
issued currencies that were backed by
all sorts of things and let the market
decide you know what they prefer let
merchants decide what they want to
accept as painted for their goods and
services and let consumers decide what
they want to save but the last the last
thing that government was the governor
doesn't want people to have a choice
because what they're providing is lousy
right the US dollar the year at the end
are lousy monetary substitutes because
they are designed to lose value every
year you want money to preserve its
value especially if you're saving it for
the future you want the money to have
more value in the future because you're
deferring your consumption you should be
compensated for not having something
today if you have to wait five or ten
years you should have more and that's
the Connie gaining value and a positive
interest rate so this would be good and
you did even if Lieber has launched the
way you know they're currently
presenting it it potentially could be a
good thing because there is a basket of
currencies and liebherr liebherr is
gonna be backed by the dollar and euro
the end R&B you know whatever I'm not
sure the exact competition composition
but it's not going to be a fixed basket
you're gonna have this Liebherr
association that's going to be able to
you know kind of manage the portfolio of
assets which will mainly be government
bonds short-term government bonds but in
theory then they can look at
government's that are more fiscally
reckless that are running bigger
deficits and printing more money
and decide to reduce the Reserve
Component of that currency or eliminated
and if another country started to be all
of a sudden with sound money they were
right budget surpluses and they were
cutting government spending and doing
things that are positive for the long
term value maybe Liebherr can add that
to the basket or you know increase its
allocation and so if that being included
in that basket became important well
then it would be a positive influence on
governments around the world towards
fiscal responsibility the reason that
governments don't want that is they
don't want
Disko responsibility they don't want any
discipline they want to be able to keep
on spend you can keep on borrowing and
they want the least pressure against
that because that's how they they get
elected so one of the questions then
would be let's say that there is a
breakdown in the dollar and gold would
benefit and people would flee to gold
wouldn't the government just ban the
ownership of gold like they did in there
was it the third wheel well you know
when Roosevelt basically made it illegal
for Americans to own gold 1933 we were
on a gold standard you know and the
whole thing that everything they did was
illegal but he got away with it but
Roosevelt wanted to devalue the dollar
but in order to do that he had to take
everybody's gold because the dollar was
defined legally as twenty dollars was an
ounce of gold and so in order to devalue
the dollar he needed to get everybody's
goals that's what he did and as soon as
he did that he devalue the dollar and
now you needed thirty five dollars to
get an ounce of gold instead of twenty
but in order to devalue the Federal
Reserve Note because it's not even
really a dollar but let's just call it a
dollar because people think it's a
dollar but in order the value of the
dollar today all you have to do is print
them we're not on a gold standard there
is no value of the dollar it doesn't
have to beat the value to just
appreciate you just debase it by
creating it out of thin air so there is
no real reason for the government to
seize gold the way it sees it under
Roosevelt now maybe the government is
broke and needs money and they start
seizing gold but if they're gonna see is
gold I mean why does
oh why Nazis stops why Nazis foreign
currency why Nazis real-estate I mean
you're talking about the government just
confiscating private wealth private
assets because it's broke and personally
it's I think it's easier for the
government that seize your stocks and it
sees your real estate then the sees your
bold because they know where your stocks
are there in a brokerage account they
have to have all the information they
know exactly where your money is if you
have a bank account if you have foreign
currencies but if you have gold they
don't know where you happen if you own
it yourself and you've buried it
somewhere you know you have it in a
private safe it's much harder for the
government to get your goal and you know
they can seize your crypto currencies to
I mean I think it'd be easier for the
government to seize your Bitcoin it's
Bitcoin for sure can't be seized right
it's a non seasonable asset because of
the cryptography and the private keys
component of it so don't you think that
if the government started to seize
assets Bitcoin would be the last thing
that they could get and they will have
to mentally torture you to give up the
private keys right well there was just
an article I read about they just busted
this child porn ring based on following
the the Bitcoin trail they were able to
figure out who these guys were and who
was you know buying stuff and so maybe
the government can't seize your Bitcoin
but they can find out the beneficial
owners of these wallets they can use
tools on the Internet to kind of tie you
to your wallet and it's like okay you
know turn this in or you know you're
going to jail I mean if they can find
you right you know and they can they can
also criminalize the use because it's
easy they could say okay no Ben and
nobody could use Bitcoin if anybody's
caught using Bitcoin it's twenty years
in jail or you know whatever they caught
they could make the death penalty if
they wanted to but you know it would be
easier to stop the use I would think
then to stop because I can hand somebody
gold in an alley
nobody knows that I did it right I mean
if you're if you're transacting through
the internet you're always leaving some
kind of you know trace that your your
other things so but at least we agree
that the to have an asset that can't be
seized by the government what has some
value right yeah I mean you know if it's
an asset you're safe but Bitcoin you
know it's arguable whether or not it's
you know you know I'm gonna have any
value but you know if you can say the
government can't theoretically seize it
you know because they didn't know I
guess you know what if they just seize
your cell phone in your computer
I mean you had the private yeah yeah
although I mean you could forget the
private key right then and then it's
gone yeah of course you could but you
could forget the the password or the you
can forget where you buried your gold I
get that yeah I mean you know I suppose
you buried your gold
some people do just check and just check
in alright so at least that piece the
other piece of this I guess is to me you
talked about like being able to use gold
for transactions right like to handset
somebody in the dark alley etc I think
we both agree that gold is not nearly as
portable as like fiat currency or a
digital currency right doesn't
necessarily mean that that's a bad thing
but just the carrying around bars of
gold it would probably not be the most
effective thing right well I mean gold
is very portable from the perspective of
you know if you have ten thousand 50
thousand dollars worth of gold you know
I can carry that in my pockets I can
carry that in a small briefcase and it
wouldn't really be that big a deal I
mean so it's there is a lot of value
concentrated yes if you want if you're
talking about 100 million dollars worth
of gold yeah you know that's you know
that's gonna be you know cumbersome but
for most people gold is a pretty
portable I mean that's one of the
reasons that that is that it's made such
good money it was easy to carry it
around because a lot of value is
concentrated in a small area but you
know the other thing that you could do
goal is like I described or like you do
with gold money you can have gold on
deposit in a vault and I can transfer
ownership of that bold to another
individual so if I wanted to send my
goal to somebody in Germany I don't have
to physically send him my bowl if I have
it stored with a reliable third party
like cold money and all I do is simply
send him over the Internet the ownership
rights to my goal and now it transfers
from me to him and that's so it's very
portable it's just I just sent it across
the Atlantic and it happened
instantaneously I didn't have to you
know spend any money on shipping because
the gold stays in the wall the vault
might be in London the vault might be in
Hong Kong or Singapore Dubai or Toronto
right the gold hasn't moved but I'm able
to transfer ownership of that gold
pretty much anywhere I want and that you
know that basically would you know
deliver the same result all right but at
least we agree that Bitcoin is more
portable so gold may you could put in
your pocket or in their small brief yes
right Bitcoin yes what one of the good
things about big point yes I can have a
billion dollars worth of Bitcoin and I
can go through you know the airport
sensors and nothing is going to go off I
can get on a plane although I do think
that you know I think you have to and
I'm not sure if you have to disclose or
if they pass that law but if you get on
a plane now you know how you have to
save it you have if you have more than
ten thousand dollars worth of courtesy
you've got to check this box that I got
ten thousand dollars the currency I'm
not sure if you have to do that if you
have ten thousand dollars with a big
point yeah but I think there was a law
or they were considering requiring now
they don't know if it passed or not but
that would mean almost anybody right cuz
if you have ten thousand dollars with a
big point every time you got on a plane
you know you're carrying it with you
yeah but I don't but you're not
technically carrying it with you right
you're carrying the password but that
doesn't mean that you have the Bitcoin
with you
well that's true because I guess no one
actually has it with you because it
doesn't really exist but you have yeah
you have access to but I know there was
they they were thinking about passing
I don't know if it actually was enacted
or not yeah I don't think that one got
got anywhere did so at least I
appreciate you doing this because I
think that we're making progress on the
ideas of you know Bitcoin being a scarce
asset it being portable it being
resistant to seizure one of the other
elements that I think the Bitcoin
community really gets excited about and
I want to hear your thoughts on is the
lack of censorship with Bitcoin right so
the fact that it's decentralized it can
be sent to anyone in the world and no
one can stop that transaction has a lot
of value also some people that that
concerns them but when you look at gold
versus Bitcoin around censorship how do
you think about that yeah well look I
mean that is obviously part of the
appeal I mean part of the the sizzle
right because there's no state but part
of the sizzle that sold Bitcoin is all
those other attributes that oh yeah you
know that these other monetary
attributes that it has but you know a
lot of has even been lost because I even
remember that early on one of the big
arguments in favor Bitcoin was it was
anonymous and no but you can you can get
rid of you know bypass all the
government rules because they they had
been putting on more rules and more
regulations with anti money laundering
in fact uh and it was getting very
expensive and you have to give all kinds
of financial information about yourself
to send wires and and do all that and I
offer it a bank and I see all that
regulation and all that loss of privacy
that we know how fact I used to have my
bank we used to have the words privacy
assured and we had to get rid of that
there's no private accounts anymore you
can't even offer privacy because if you
do like nobody will do business with you
so there's no more financial privacy and
so initially part of the appeal of
Bitcoin was hey this is a way around
that this is a way to be private and and
privacy is a good thing probably having
privacy from government is important the
reason that government doesn't like five
a-- c is because if they're going to be
tyrannical they want to be able to quell
any kind of revolution they want to be
able to get you know make sure that they
can maintain their hold on the economy
on the populace and they can do that
better if there's no privacy so once you
destroy
by becae you make it harder for the
people to rebel against tyrannical
government and so that's where we are
but Bitcoin you know offered that
promise hey this you can escape all this
but when they wanted to make Bitcoin
more mainstream because they wanted
institutional investors because they
needed new buyers to come in and push
the price higher the institution is
needed regulatory you know they needed
this surveillance they needed all this
regulation that you get all this kyc and
you know and so now all of a sudden
there's all this stuff people you want
to buy Bitcoin you want to open up an
account you got to give your driver
slice you got to give your password
here's your utility bill now you know a
lot of that privacy that initially made
bit call Bitcoin appealing has been lost
and now there are other coins that are
supposedly you know private my Monaro or
whatever they are but bitcoin has kind
of lost that but it didn't stop you know
the narrative and people from buying
Bitcoin and speculating it even as you
know it lost some of the original you
know justification of its appeal well I
think part of it is that the asset stuff
itself still has the pseudonymity and
can be used privately it's you're
talking about if the on and off ramps
that are being offered many of them
require the KYC naml kind of adherence
or compatibility and that's where people
are having to disclose their identities
etc and so if you go in through one of
those on or off ramps from the fiat
world it's much harder to have let's see
you got yeah they're controlling those
ramps a you know the the most ironic
part of it is that guy you know the a
grayscale let's doing the GB that the
Bitcoin trust it's running all these
dumb gold campaigns I mean this guy I
mean I can see if someone's gonna buy
Bitcoin what's the point of buying it in
this trust because you lose all the
appeal because now you have a third
party storing your Bitcoin you're
actually paying a 2% per year storage
fee I mean nobody who stores
for you charges you that much money I
mean if you store gold for you know gold
storage companies typically charge maybe
25 basis points to 50 basis points a
year to store your gold and and when
they try to knock gold well all those
expensive the store well if you're
paying two percent to greyscale to store
your Bitcoin I mean that's you know much
much more than you would pay to store
gold so you're having these expensive
storage fees you're also having to pay
brokerage fees to buy and sell it as
you're buying the stuff the fun now and
you've got your your your Bitcoin store
with a third party I mean so that makes
the least sense to me that anybody if
anybody actually wanted to buy Bitcoin
it makes no sense that they would buy it
through an ETF and extraordinaire and
fun right and now they and all the big
corners want these ETFs right they want
more ETFs because this one did that this
fun is not neat yeah but the reason they
want to ETF is because they want more
demand they want the ETF's to buy
Bitcoin that bit up the price but why
would you find in an ETF it makes no
sense because you lose all the appeal of
the asset by holding it in DTF but the
whole desire is just to get more buying
so the price will go up and and so as
you look out at this entire world what
do you think ends up occurring with
Bitcoin in the regulation environment so
you're talking about the each
specifically right and we've seen that
not get approved how do you think this
plays out given kind of the historical
way that gold played out and then also
you know kind of kind of the I want to
say the fear but but definitely the
skepticism of a lot of people in the
regulatory and and lawmaking seats a
Bitcoin like how does this play out
yeah well the regulatory aspects are
serious road walk I mean I see that look
you know I've had lots of crypto
companies over the years wanting to open
up accounts with my bank you're a
Pacific Bank I've had to turn them all
down I mean I actually had a guy one
time that sent money in who was Europe
Pacific account from big bold which
would
the original name of of gold money and I
couldn't even take it because the banks
were worried about it because it had the
word bit it was became from big bold
just because it had the word bit in it
even though it wasn't a cryptocurrency
so it's like it's like poison like the
banks the banking community can't touch
any of this stuff because of the
regulatory environment that we're in and
other companies that I'm associated with
I can feel the heat of the regulators
the minute you try to get into any
crypto I mean you're just in the
crosshairs I mean you're gonna be
bombarded and I don't I don't see that
lightening up I mean I just you know the
government's do feel threatened whether
the threat is legitimate or not I mean
you know I don't believe that ultimately
Bitcoin can succeed is money but a lot
of these politicians they don't know
that they can be just as fooled I mean
yeah one of these congressmen that was
in the hearing with took over the other
day who actually thought that Bitcoin
potentially was a threat to replace the
dollar and to the extent that they think
that that's a threat they're gonna do
everything that they can to extinguish
that threat and so the regulatory force
is gonna is gonna continue to bear down
on Bitcoin and crypto and anything that
has to do with it
you know I'm not in favor of that right
I don't want any of this regulation I
mean I think look these crypto
currencies should be allowed to be there
people should be allowed to gamble on
them if they want if people want to buy
them I don't think there should be fraud
like I think some people are being
defrauded into buying Bitcoin and I
think that they might have a legal case
when they lose their money but to the
extent that people are honestly exposed
to it and making decisions to buy it I
thought the government should stay away
and let the markets decide you know and
if they fail they fail but you know
that's not how the government works the
government is over regulating everything
but in particular crypto currencies are
getting a lot of regulation and what I'm
really afraid of too is when a lot of
people do lose money because Bitcoin
crashes and a lot of people lose money
they are gonna take that as an
opportunity to really step off the
regulation and you know this is though
the ultimate failure of Bitcoin is if it
ends up serving the interests of
government by helping to you know
validate their fears of the free
oh you see the free market it's terrible
got people scammed in the Bitcoin and
you know real the dollar is the best and
this is you know we gotta we need more
regulation to protect consumers to
protect investors you know from this
kind of fraud and they just make
government even bigger and we Bitcoin
actually ends up making the dollar look
girl right by comparison because people
lose even more money there nah not gonna
happen
let's talk let's talk about Twitter and
media you've built a much bigger media
platform that I think many people
realize you've got what like quarter
million subscribers on YouTube you got a
pretty big Twitter account you got a
podcast that does quite a bit of
downloads etc like what what's your
whole take on what you're trying to do
with with the media and the social media
platforms yeah well you know when the
scheme of things is still kind of low I
mean I have kids young kids that you
know watch YouTube videos that other
kids are putting on they got millions
and millions of views you know just kids
playing with toys so you know my you
know my little world is kind of small
even though I bet you've got more
Twitter followers than I do how did you
get all those Twitter followers that's
because bitcoin is better than gold so
yeah I said you're the consensus trade
on experience but yeah you know I mean
hopefully the way I am interacting with
people now is through the internet you
know I was in an airplane you know the
other day and I usually get recognized
by somebody when I travel by plane but
I'm gonna plane and I'm talking to
somebody and somebody comes up to me
because they said okay your ship you
know I recognized your voice right say
did they they knew I was on the plane
because they heard me talking and so
people used to recognize me cuz they
used to see me on TV and so they
recognized me cus you know because for a
while I was on all the time and I
especially when I used to walk in
Manhattan I would always get recognized
several times a day because I was on all
the time and people in New York tended
to know me but now people are
recognizing me by my voice not by the
way I look but they're used to hearing
my voice
so yeah I'm but um
this is how I'm communicating now my
thoughts and my
is because I'm I don't really have the
mainstream media platform anymore that I
used to a decade ago but back then I
didn't have a YouTube channel I didn't
have you know Twitter I didn't have my
podcasts so you know and and I know look
what I just posted a video of a talk
that I did at the money show and I've
got over 200,000 views on it in the last
week I mean I didn't think 2 or 200,000
people didn't watch me on CNBC I don't
even think they have a single show that
has that big an audience you know so in
a way more people are exposed to me now
when I'm doing it myself then when I you
know have the help of these media
outlets got it and then how do you think
about Twitter like like you you get on
there and you go to battle every day
with the hoe with the bitcoiners and
then you've obviously got like kind of
the gold-bug community that's that
supports you and everything and get
quite a bit of engagement but how do you
think about it don't know you know like
the last time you know I've been sick
the last week or two and you said well
I'm sitting in bed I got nothing to do
this so I just start going on Twitter
because it's entertaining and yeah I
could pick a fight I could pick a fight
with you or the interesting thing is
whenever I tweet something about Bitcoin
I mean that's when it just gets all kind
of engagement and I can do a political
tweet or you know a gold tweet you know
but the ones were if I say anything
about Bitcoin that's what I mean it's
like and not only do people respond to
it I'll put out a tweet and I'll go and
I'll google my name the next day and
they'll be 10 hours of written by
Bitcoin publications quoting my tweet I
mean that doesn't happen when I tweet
about anything else so I mean so people
are actually looking at what I have to
say when it comes to big coin and then
you know a lot of times - there's a lot
of Bitcoin trolls on my Twitter because
I'll tweet something that has nothing to
a big coin not to do with the gold and
then look at the responses and all like
people talking about Bitcoin
that's like this like this come on they
start I feed I find it amusing that that
happens and so yeah I mean I suppose if
I didn't get any attention on the
Bitcoin tweets maybe I wouldn't tweet
them but I know I
do as many as people think I mean a
people I mean in fact I haven't even got
a chance to tweet out about this rally
which I should so people don't accuse me
of being silent with bitcoins okay
because I think I think Kenny I think
they should sell this rally it's a
sucker out
people have been have been rooting at us
the entire time that we are we're doing
this interview and they're asking if
we're if we're gonna record the podcast
so they don't realize that we're doing
it literally while this rally is going
on 15 percent what's your take on that
when Bitcoin is while you're sitting
here saying it's not valuable and it
just rips 15% upwards what do you what
do I say to the people I'm quiting mean
well Bitcoin just rips up 15% like that
it's obviously got the volatility on the
upside that's something that goal
obviously never does right in terms of
big movements like that like what's your
kind of response to the people who say
hey that that's a valuable thing that
gold doesn't bring to the table the
asymmetric upside well look I've never
said that Bitcoin could not be used as a
speculative medium I mean that's the
only use that it has right you could
speculate in it because you do have
these big grips that happen right I mean
but the fact that it is this volatile
right is one of the things that makes it
so bad as a medium of exchange the fact
that you can have the currency move 10%
any given hour you know makes it a very
volatile asset and very difficult to use
is in transactions you can't price
things in it and things like that so the
only value it has is as something
speculated but you know that's the same
value that Comstock's hat or anything
like that but ultimately it's gonna it's
gonna it's gonna collapse I mean you
know there's an old joke about you know
the can of sardines that that that I
guess is bad but they they trade it you
know people are buying and selling and
but you can't eat it and I think it's
you know well these sardines are for
trading they're not for eating no one
eats if we just trade them all right
well but you know if you can't eat them
what value do they have they haven't
about but as but people could trade them
as long as they don't realize that the
the sardines are on they can find sell
them so yeah I mean look there are
people in there trading this market and
look I have
very skeptical - about the treaty I mean
why'd Bitcoin rallies I mean I think
there's a lot of manipulation in this
market it's not very transparent I do
think that a lot of the rallies are
engineered by some of the big holders
that are in there when they once they
can get the market to sell off and once
they can see that the offers are kind of
thin and they can rush in there and just
get the market to move up without having
to buy that much Bitcoin back you know
if they sell it on the way down and they
can pump the market up they can create
some enthusiasm that brings in the new
buyers as people say oh the bottom is in
we're gonna zoom the 20,000 we're gonna
moon and so they can buy just enough
Bitcoin to spike it up at the right time
so that new buyers can come in and now
they can unload even more Bigpoint and
then the price the price goes down so I
am very skeptical of these sharp rallies
they look to me like market manipulation
I mean why is Bitcoin 10% more valuable
today than it was yesterday I mean you
know there's no I mean nothing has
really changed so people if and you know
if you look at that if I wanted to buy
Bitcoin because the price went down hey
the price just went down I want to buy
Bitcoin I'm gonna buy it slowly I'm
gonna try to buy as much as I can right
as cheap as I can but when I see the
people rushing in and just taking all
the offers and jamming the price that
doesn't look like someone's trying to
buy a good price it looks likes from
when someone's trying to move the price
higher and who wants to move the price
of Bitcoin higher somebody who wants to
sell somebody who wants to buy wants the
price lower they want the price to go
down if you're a buyer you want to buy
this cheap as you can you don't want to
push the price up but if you're a seller
that's what you want a higher price so
you know I think these rallies are meant
to sucker in new buyers I think the real
money is still selling Bitcoin and and
you know and and and until we make a new
hive till we take out if we take out
twenty thousand and you know then I'm
about that and we're going higher but I
don't think I'm wrong about the ultimate
destination no matter how high he goes
but I just don't think it's worth the
bet that bitcoins gonna make it new high
I mean what if it makes a new high it
triples I think you can triple your
money and other things with less risk
all right have you ever taken fiat money
and bought Bitcoin like do you own any
Bitcoin either bring the Bitcoin that I
crown funded for you online yeah but do
you give me any Bitcoin yourself you
were supposed to give me $100 words that
I never got it this might be a good time
not if you want to get me in on that but
other people yes you you you you said
you were gonna give me a hundred hours
with a Bitcoin if I gave you my wallet
and I eventually figured out my wild
address and I put it up there and a
bunch of people gave me Bitcoin but you
to give me anything have you ever met
coin no no the only the only other way I
got Bitcoin is I did an interview a
debate rather which anybody can see on
YouTube on YouTube it was with Erik
Voorhees and it was sponsored by reason
in New York and Soho forum and we did a
Bitcoin debate and after the debate we
went out to dinner and and during while
we're at dinner
Eric downloaded the app or on my phone
of from his company when his wallet and
transferred $100 worth of Bitcoin to me
and I transferred 50 of it back right so
we could see how he could show me how
quickly he can send me $100 and I can
send him 50 but I kept 50 he gave me 50
as a gift so I got that 50 and then
after I got that 50 I went to I went to
it I went to like a money show or
something and I was talking to somebody
and I showed in my wallet he said well
you need to get some other Persis and I
was selling some of my dad's books and
so he decided to pay for the books by
giving me crypto and he gave me Bitcoin
cash and ether for those those two books
that he bought and so he exchanged it
into my wallet but because he was giving
Krypto I charged him extra in the cash
right so I charging like a 50% more
because of the risk of me be taking
crypto and I there were actually they've
now gone down so much that you know the
50% wasn't enough I should have charged
him double because my ether in my
Bitcoin cache are worth less than what I
went with the with the regular price the
books would have been but that was only
like another 40 bucks worth right
because I charged him like or I forget
or 30 bucks worth but but that's it but
I've never actually I've never actually
taken my own money and bought Bitcoin
now am i proud of that I mean you know I
mean like obviously you know III I wish
I'd have done it I mean I wish I had
done it the first time I heard about it
right when I first heard about it you
know it was under $20 you know and I
thought it was interesting and at the
time I was throwing a lot of money at a
lot of stupid things and III made
investments that that went to zero and I
had you know I I could have thrown
10,000 50,000 100,000 you know I could
have put that money into Bitcoin and I'd
be a Bitcoin billionaire right now
assuming I I held on me because it's
always hard to would it could have [ __ ]
it right I could always say you know had
I bought and way back win what would I
have done with it but I can tell you
from history I mean I in general I don't
sell a lot of things I mean I'm I'm a
better buyer than I am selling you know
so it's possible though I might not have
sold some of those early rallies I might
have I might have held on those but I'm
you know I look there's a lot of bubbles
that I didn't participate in I didn't
buy a the dot-coms
I didn't buy real estate you know I was
renting I mean but you know I made money
when the bubbles popped and I think
Bitcoin is just part of this big bubble
and I think I'm gonna make a lot of
money when that bubble pops even though
I didn't make any money betting on it
I'm gonna make money betting against it
all right before I let you go I do
rapid-fire set of questions what's the
most important book you've ever read
yeah yeah right it requires more
thinking than add you know I don't
really know I mean my father's books are
probably had the most influence on me
because my father wrote them but
you know that that caused me to read
other books right look well his biggest
his economic book was the biggest con
how the government was fleecing you and
so that book came out in nineteen 176 or
something and so it's one of the first
books on economics that I read although
my father had me read the mainspring of
human progress and I also read Henry
Haslam's book economics had one lesson
early on and so that was a very
influential book on me cuz I mean I read
it when I was very young and then I
Lenny's podcast I'll let you ask me one
question but before we do that we talked
a lenience a weber or non-believer think
they're real well do I think aliens
exist somewhere in the universe
definitely I mean do I think that any of
them have visited earth probably not but
I do I don't think that humans are the
only intelligent life in the entire
universe but I do think that the
likelihood of their being humans or any
intelligent life within a proximity that
they could visit us I think that's
pretty slim because I think that I think
intelligent life is very very rare in
the universe and it they're all it takes
a really you know amazing confluence of
things in order to have life like us
evolved and so I think we are very rare
but I don't think we are are unique if
you had to guess all of this speculation
and conspiracy theories etc around UFOs
aliens all that kind of stuff you think
it's all just [ __ ] or you think that
there's actually some validity to it now
I think most conspiracy theories are our
[ __ ] you know I mean you know III
think Elvis is dead you know I mean I
think we you know we landed on the moon
you know there are a lot of people you
know come up with these things and they
develop a life of their own but you know
generally the thing about conspiracies
is it's very hard to actually keep the
conspiracy going you know the people
having to be silent about it I mean
somebody is gonna slip up
but you know I think there you know you
know they certainly have an appeal and
there are a lot of people that tend to
gravitate to them and some of them
obviously are in the gold community
right at the libertarian commuters that
you know there's a fringe there in fact
there's a lot of people I think there's
a big conspiracy to suppress the price
of gold and look you know there's no
question that central bankers don't want
the price of gold to go up because I
think us you know it's it's like a
canary in a coal mine right when the
price of gold is going up it really
shows you that there's a problem and so
the central bankers don't want the
miners leaving leaving the the cave when
their intention is to gas everybody but
I don't think there's a grand conspiracy
to suppress it I just think it's you
know it's undervalued because a lot of
people don't understand what's going on
I think the central banks and
governments have been successful in
convincing people that everything is
okay and I think you have you know the
investment community goes along with it
you know because it serves their
interest they make a lot of money from
this game and you know there's an old
saying if your livelihood depends on you
not understanding something you're not
going to understand it and so I think
that a lot of people make a living off
of this system they make a very good
living and so they don't want to you
know look it in the mouth look at you
know they just want to perpetuate it and
but eventually all these things come to
an end and so you know the price of gold
is going way up you know if the
government could suppress the price of
gold they wouldn't let it rally from 300
under 300 in 2001 to 1900 that they
could have stopped it they would have
think they could had a big rally and
it's gonna have an even bigger rally
next time what will a question you got
for me to end this thing this is a
marathon man an hour I know I can't I
can't believe I had an appointment I
wonder if you I had an immediate and I
wonder what the hell happened because I
thought this was gonna be over in an
hour and we're almost two hours yeah
well you know when you're talking about
real sound money like Bitcoin is what
happens you can't leave people get mad
do they think my podcasts I think will
think my podcasts are too long when I
talk for 50 minutes to an hour so this
one is this one is two hours where I'll
make you famous in Bitcoin Twitter come
out look right so Mike
so you posted something on Twitter that
you wanted to sponsor my podcast and you
know you actually offered to pay me five
dollars or listener and you know I I
don't I would feel guilty taking that
much money from you but but you know but
I decided I did agree to fifty grand a
month
you know because you wanted to sponsor
sponsor November December
so the offers still on the table if you
want to sponsor my podcast you can even
pay me too but you could even pay me in
Bitcoin
tell us how many people would be part
how many listeners even on that thing
well I don't know exactly how many I
have but I could find out if you're
gonna pay me $5 elicitor but look you
could look I I know we get fifty to a
hundred thousand people that just go to
ship radio and listen to it I'm not sure
how I know you know people listen to it
from you know iTunes and stitcher these
different things but people on my
youtube I mean my I had I did want on my
youtube when I popped my podcast I'm
within a couple weeks ago I got over a
hundred thousand listeners just on
YouTube alone but typically that I get
forty to fifty thousand people to listen
to it on on on YouTube too but then
other people copy it so you know my
podcasts get you know copied and then
people listen to them on other people's
channels you know you know so I just
don't know what the the total
listenership is but I think somewhere
between a hundred and two hundred
thousand people probably listen to each
one you know and and and then if one is
really popular you know I could get more
listeners than that but I think you know
at least a hundred thousand listened to
everyone that I do mean between the
podcast and YouTube to be completely
honest that's pretty impressive I gotta
hand it to you if you're getting that
type of listener Bay shirt you're either
saying some wild [ __ ] that people can or
you're saying something and you know I
don't have any commercials or any
sponsors so you would be the first one
right there's
you know a lot you know although I do I
think when people go on YouTube you know
before they watch it I think you know
there's some commercials that run you
know I don't know I think I think I
opted into that so I do get a you know I
do get some revenue chair from some
commercial a lot of times they're crypto
commercials people laugh there's a lot
of like you know cryptocurrency
commercials that come on it before my
pocket yeah cool well of course because
they know that the gold people are just
lost or wait to find Bitcoin it's taking
the time to do this I think that as
always people are excited to hear your
point of view you know you're basically
a bit corner without owning any Bitcoin
with with most of your views we'll just
got to get you across the the final
finish line there but we're gonna try to
get you guys you cry you're a gold guy I
just see I just got to get the Bitcoin
guys into real money right they they
don't like the Fiat system and they want
out they just they just they're just
going the wrong way I just got to get
them back to real funny or you know it's
Starbucks you know at least on both you
know at least make sure you own enough
bold so if your crypto goes to zero
you'll be okay with your gold I'll make
you deal if I buy a little bit of gold
will you buy some Bitcoin Wow I mean
yeah I mean there I don't know how much
would I have to buy because throwing my
money away the same amount I buy was an
amount and the reason I want to throw
money away hey everyone pop here if you
like this episode of off the chain and
want to help us take crypto to the top
of the Apple Spotify and other podcast
charts please do us a favor and rate
review and subscribe to review simply go
to the off-the-chain homepage scroll
down until you see the five blank stars
taking 15 seconds to fill those stars in
and leave a quick review goes a long way
in helping us take the entire crypto
ecosystem to the top of the charts I
appreciate you listening and see you
next time on off the chain